utiliza la gráfica para contestar la
pregunta tenemos aquí una gráfica y la
pregunta es cuántos estudiantes
mejoraron sus calificaciones del examen
de mitad de curso al examen final y con
esto lo que podemos ver es que tenemos
en este eje los puntos que sacaron en el
examen y en este eje horizontal los
nombres de cada estudiante recuerda que
la barra azul nos indica la calificación
parcial o aquella de mitad de curso y el
amarillo nos indica la calificación que
tuvieron al final y si nuestra pregunta
es cuántos estudiantes mejoraron sus
calificaciones eso implicaría que la
barra amarilla pues se ha incrementado
es mayor que el azul dado que esta vez
en el examen final han sacado una mejor
calificación y por lo tanto se marca más
grande vamos a ver
christopher en el primer examen sacó 90
y en el segundo saco 75 esto implica que
disminuyó de hecho aquí podemos ver cómo
esta barra amarilla es más pequeña que
el azul por lo tanto no podemos contar a
christopher
que haya incrementado o mejorado sus
calificaciones
sin embargo vanessa nos muestra la otra
parte la barra amarilla que nos
representa el examen final es más alta
que la calificación que tuvo en el
examen parcial o de mitad de curso por
lo tanto este es el patrón que estamos
buscando donde la columna amarilla es
mayor que el azul tenemos el caso de
vanessa tenemos el caso de sant en la
que también vemos como la calificación
del final fue mayor mismo caso con
ashley y con gabriela tenemos que ella
había sacado 100 y ahora sacó 95 la
calificación del examen final es más
pequeña que la calificación que ella
había obtenido
el examen parcial por lo tanto si la
pregunta es cuántos estudiantes
mejoraron sus calificaciones tenemos el
caso de vanessa y yang y ashley son 123
tres estudiantes son los que han
mejorado esa calificación comprobemos
respuesta y es correcta vamos a hacer
una más
utilizaremos la gráfica para contestar
la pregunta cuál estudiante mejor o por
más punto su calificación en el examen
de mitad de curso y el examen final esto
ya lo habíamos visto en el ejercicio
pasado estamos buscando la mejora es
decir que la barra del examen final es
más alto que el examen parcial de
entrada descartaremos a jessica ya
gabriela y sólo dejaremos a ashley y
mary y christopher que son los tres que
tienen un incremento de su examen
parcial al final ahora nos están
preguntando cuál de ellos mejoró por más
puntos y tenemos a ashley quien en el
primer examen sacó 70 lo podemos ver
aquí 70 en el parcial y en el segundo
saco 85 ella tuvo un incremento o mejoró
por 15 puntos hay que mantenerlo en
mente 15 puntos
emily había sacado 60 en el primer
examen y se fue hasta 85 en el examen
final eso indica que ella mejoró de 60 a
es decir hay 25 puntos de diferencia
entre su examen parcial
final comparativamente podemos decir que
emily hasta el momento es la que más ha
mejorado dado que ashley sólo tenía 15
puntos de mejora y emily tiene 25
mantengamos eso en mente
finalmente christopher que es el otro
estudiante que mejoró sus calificaciones
del examen parcial al examen final él
sacó 60 en el primer examen igual que
emily y en el examen final sacó 80 80
puntos es decir mejoró en 20 puntos la
calificación que tenía sin embargo no es
suficiente como para rebasar a emily
emily tuvo 25
christopher tuvo un incremento de 20
puntos y ashley sólo de 15 por lo que
podemos decir que el estudiante que
mejoró por más puntos bueno pues ese mil
y emily es nuestra respuesta correcta
vamos a comprobar respuesta y es
correcta
nos vemos en otro vídeo